6 octobre 1789 louis saez remet les clés
à son ministre de la guerre vont faire
la tournée pas tâcher de me sauver mon
pauvre versailles choses extraordinaires
au coeur de la révolution le château
comme un navire abandonné continue sur
son air pendant trois ans on
l'entretient ont leur pain on le
bichonne jamais il n'a été aussi propre
aussi beau mais cela ne dure pas on
commence par vendre le mobilier puis
charles de la croix le père du peintre
réclame sa destruction à cor et à cri on
propose diverses affectations hôpital
auspices écoles finalement louis
philippe à l'idée de faire de ce symbole
de la royauté le temple de la
réconciliation nationale
voici l'inauguration de son fameux musée
d'histoire dédiés comme le proclament
les frontons à toutes les gloires de la
france le château et sauver
définitivement
mais à l'intérieur la casse est
considérable les charmant appartement du
xviiie siècle sont remplacés par ces
enfilade de pièces monotone que les
conservateurs actuels ont eu bien du
mérite à rajeunir
en revanche toute l'histoire de france
des croisades à la guerre de 14 et l'a
accroché au mur six mille tableaux 2000
sculptures les événements les hommes les
batailles héroïques
c'est d'un coût 150 salles fermées pour
travaux depuis 20 ans qui sont livrés à
l'appétit des écoliers
bonjour voici dix panneaux gré sans mise
en 1837 il ya eu 25 mille personnes et
dix mille 10 mx se sont poursuivies
après ça pendant des mois et des mois et
2 qui nous ouvrons nos salles
historiques les gens s'y précipitent
douzaine d'histoires et ils aiment voir
la façon dont elle est racontée à
l'image et en couleurs et pourquoi
ont-elles été fermée si longtemps nous
avons eu premièrement à restaurer un
certain nombre de ces salles et
deuxièmement nous avons des problèmes de
gardiennage le château est immense vous
connaissez nous ne pouvons pas tout
ouvrir en même temps et c'est un de nos
gros produit est ce que le 2 juin toutes
les salles du musée sont ouvertes pas
tout mais deux tiers ou les trois quarts
ce qui est déjà énorme et qui remplit
largement la journée d'un touriste sow
lyng et quand le musée extractives
ouvert complètement d'ici un an un an et
demi maintenant